>>> WEDNESDAY WILL MARK 25 YEARS
SINCE PRINCESS DIANA DIED AFTER
A CAR CRASH IN A PARIS TUNNEL.
HER BOYS WHO WALKED SOLEMNLY
BEHIND THE CASKET A QUARTER
CENTURY AGO ARE ALL GROWN UP
NOW.
OF COURSE PRINCE WILLIAM IS
PREPARING TO BE KING SOME DAY,
AND HARRY HAS STEPPED BACK FROM
THE ROYAL LIFE.
MEANWHILE, PRINCE CHARLES IS
STILL WAITING.
TINA BROWN HAS A FASCINATING
BOOK OUT ON ALL OF IT.
INSIDE THE HOUSE OF WINDSOR, THE
TRUTH AND THE TURMOIL.
AND SHE JOINS ME NOW.
SO LET ME FIRST START BY ASKING
YOU, DIANA'S DEATH, I REMEMBER
IT VIVIDLY AND THE FEELING THAT
THERE WAS ALMOST THIS KIND OF
BREAK IN THE BRITISH PSYCHE,
THERE WAS AN ERUPTION OF
MOMENTS.
>> IT WAS A MOMENT WHEN THE
CONNECTION THAT DIANA HAD
FORGED, HER COMBINATION OF ROYAL
CHARISMA IF YOU WOULD LIKE AND
HUMANITARIAN WARMTH, THE WAY SHE
REACHED OUT TO PEOPLE AND SHARED
HER PAIN, WHICH IS AN ABSOLUTELY
NEW THING FOR ANY ROYAL TO DO,
THE WAS THE MOMENT WHEN YOU SAW
FOR THE FIRST TIME THE STIFF
UPPER LIP OF THE BRITISH
CRUMBLE, AND SUDDENLY, PEOPLE
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE, ALL AGE
GROUPS WERE WEEPING IN THE
STREETS OF LONDON AND ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
>> AND YET, THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT BRITAINS AND PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD SEEM TO ADMIRE ABOUT
THAT STIFF UPPER LIP WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE QUEEN WHO HAS
PLAYED THIS REMARKABLE ROLE OF
REALLY NEVER REVEALING ANYTHING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I MEAN, THE QUEEN NEVER
EXPLAINED, NEVER COMPLAINED.
AND OF COURSE, DIANA DIDN'T
DEPART FROM THAT.
WE KNOW NOTHING ABOUT WHAT THE
QUEEN THINKS ABOUT ANYTHING.
70 YEARS ON THE THRONE, SHE'S
ACTUALLY PERFECTED THE ART OF
ALLOWING ANYONE TO PROJECT WHAT
THEY WANT ON HER.
WE CAN ALL LOOK AT HER AND THINK
SHE'S UPSET, SHE'S AMUSED, SHE'S
PLEASED.
THE FAMOUS BOOT SETTING AT
WEDDINGS, SHE IS 100%
INSCRUTABLE, AND THAT IS THE WAY
SHE HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
>> BUT IT MUST TAKE INCREDIBLE
DISCIPLINE TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DO WE NOT KNOW
WHAT SHE THINKS ABOUT ANYTHING,
WE NEVER WILL.
THERE WILL NEVER BE A MEMOIR
WRITTEN BY THIS WOMAN HAS BEEN
AT THE CENTER OF INTERNATIONAL
LIFE.
EVEN PEOPLE WHO SEEM INSCRUTABLE
LIKE A PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW IN
FIVE YEARS YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
MEMOIR TELLING YOU EVERYTHING.
>> SHE HAS HAD THIS REMARKABLE
SELF DISCIPLINE, AND SHE ALWAYS
HAD.
THE QUEEN WAS ALWAYS NOTED TO BE
REMARKABLY COMPOSED AND SERIOUS
MINDED.
SHE HAD ABSORBED THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF DUTY FROM HER FATHER
AND HAS NEVER LEFT FROM IT AT
ALL.
WHAT WAS HARD FOR THE QUEEN, WAS
SUDDENLY SHE WAS REQUIRED TO BE
SOMETHING ELSE.
SHE HAD ALWAYS HER LIFE FOLLOWED
THIS CREED OF RESERVE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN PEOPLE WANTED
HER TO BE CRYING AND SAYING, I'M
SO UPSET ABOUT THE DEATH OF MY
DAUGHTER.
AND SHE DIDN'T.
THAT'S THE ONLY TIME SHE DID
WRONG WITH THE PEOPLE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANTED.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF WHAT
HARRY AND WILLIAM HAVE DONE?
>> THEY'VE GONE IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
NOW THEY'RE ALL ABOUT EMOTION
ALL THE TIME.
OF COURSE THE OPRAH INTERVIEW
STUNNED AND FLOORED THE ROYAL
FAMILY.
IN A WAY, IT WAS ALMOST MORE
TRAUMATIC THAN THEM THAN DIANA'S
FAMOUS INTERVIEW BECAUSE THEY
HAD ALMOST COME TO EXPECT FROM
DIANA THESE KINDS OF NEWS BOMBS
AND REVEALING OF HERSELF AT THAT
TIME.
BUT IN THIS CASE, I THINK THEY
WERE LIKE, WHY, WHY ARE THEY
DOING THIS, AND I THINK THAT IT
ACTUALLY -- I THINK THERE WAS A
POSSIBILITY FOR THEM TO BUILD A
BRIDGE WITH THE FAMILY AFTER
THEY LEFT.
BUT THE OPRAH INTERVIEW SEEMED
LIKE A HAND GRENADE INTO THE
HOUSE OF WINDSOR, THEY HAVEN'T
REALLY RECOVERED FROM.
>> IT SEEMED TO ME THERE WAS A
FUNDAMENTAL BREAK WITH THE
BUSINESS MODEL IF YOU WILL OF
THE ROYAL FAMILY.
AS I UNDERSTOOD IT, IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE BRITISH ROYAL
FAMILY, YOU GET ENORMOUS
RESPECT, DIGNITY, WORLD-WIDE
PUBLICITY ACCLAIM, BUT YOU
BEHAVE IN A CERTAIN WAY, AND YOU
DON'T MONETIZE THE BRAND.
THAT REALLY IS FROWNED UPON.
WITH HARRY, IT SEEMED LIKE HE
SUDDENLY REALIZED, WAIT A
MINUTE, WHY DO I HAVE TO LIVE
OFF THE SCRAPS THAT CHARLES
GIVES ME?
I CAN DO A NETFLIX DEAL.
>> RIGHT.
IN MANY WAYS, A LOT OF PEOPLE I
SPOKE TO ALMOST FELT IT WAS
ALWAYS GOING TO HAPPEN THAT
HARRY WOULD LEAVE.
HE JUST COULDN'T FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO DO IT.
AND WHAT MEGHAN GAVE HIM WAS A
WAY OUT.
>> WHERE DOES PRINCE CHARLES FIT
INTO ALL THIS?
>> CHARLES HAS BEEN THE MAN WHO
WAITED IN THE WAITING ROOM OF
HIS DESTINY FOR THE LAST 50
YEARS AND HAS WAITED AND WAITED
AND WAITED.
SO HE'S FELT TREMENDOUS
FRUSTRATION IN HIS OWN LIFE, BUT
HE'S HELD ON.
YOU SAW WHEN HE HAD TO OPEN
PARLIAMENT RECENTLY WHEN THE
QUEEN WAS TOO UNWELL TO DO SO,
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE HERE HE IS,
STILL NOT KING, KIND OF ALMOST
LOOKING FOR THE CROWN ON A
CUSHION.
OPENING PARLIAMENT ONCE AGAIN
FOR HIS MOTHER, IT WAS LIKE WHEN
IS HE GOING TO BE ABLE TO STEP
INTO HIS DESTINY?
WILL HE STILL HAVE ANY YEARS
LEFT?
SO HE'S WAITING PATIENTLY.
I THINK HE WILL BE A GOOD
TRANSITIONAL MONARCH.
IT WON'T BE A LONG REIGN, BUT HE
WILL BE A GOOT CONVENING KING.
>> AND IT DOES FEEL THE ISSUE OF
IT IN THE AGE WE LIVE IN OF THIS
SUPERWEALTH, THE ISSUE OF MONEY
SOMEHOW STILL SNEAKS ITS WAY
AROUND WITH THE ROYAL FAMILY,
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
OTHER THAN THE QUEEN AND HER
STATE WEALTH, THEY'RE NOT
ACTUALLY THAT WELL OFF, SO YOU
SEE ANDREW DOING A LOT OF WHAT
HE DID, YOU SEE PRINCE CHARLES
TRYING TO FUND RAISE FROM MIDDLE
EASTERN GUYS AND TAKING CASH AND
BAGS.
>> IT'S AN ISSUE.
THEY ARE MORE AND MORE EXPOSED
TO WHAT MONEY COULD BRING THEM.
IT'S LIKE A MIRAGE.
IT ACTUALLY DOES SORT OF LEAD
THEM ASTRAY IN A SENSE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT OTHER
WAYS TO GET IT, AND USUALLY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT GETS THEM
INTO TROUBLE, MIXING WITH THE
WRONG PEOPLE OR MAKING THE WRONG
DEAL.
WITH ANDREW, IT SENT HIM OFF THE
RESERVATION AND ENDED HIM IN THE
TLOLS OF JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IN
WILLIAM AND KATE'S ERA, I FEEL
THAT THE YOUNGER CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO SAY, GO FORTH, GOD BE
WITH YOU, DON'T FEEL YOU HAVE TO
BE ROYAL IN ANY WAY.
IT'S FOR THE HEIR.
IF THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IT,
WE'LL ASK THE NEXT ONE.
BUT I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE THIS IMPRISONMENT OF TH